Paula Patton enters the videogame
fantasy world that is Warcraft as gorona
how is she not like slobbering with the
time how was I not
it began with a bit of slobber quite
frankly and an evangelist but I just I
kept wearing them all the time do
something about how does that make you
feel for what more ferocious and these
contact lenses they were each different
shades of green but they really obscured
my peripheral vision so it made me feel
less human and it was what I needed was
the inspiration I needed to feel half
worth of human a fierce role for Pola
but what does her six-year-old son
Julian think when I was at six years old
that's when I first got into gaming
Julian is he getting bears he as he
picked up any controllers he has not
picked any could I he is you know what
he loves to Brian dance parties
he likes to yes he likes to sing and
dance when do I get that from but no he
hasn't gotten the games yet no he's a
performer he's taken after dad its own
yes yes hey quite pretty I wasn't a good
singer but I love to do the exact same
thing when I was a kid yeah so did I
have the gift I didn't
[Applause]